do you think there's a chance that that
the
the compress that the time has been
compressed in a post-pandemic world
especially if there's nothing coming
on the fiscal side and i mean when i say
the fiscal side i mean checks in
people's pockets
um
first of all in terms of the definition
of a recession by the national bureau of
economic research which is the final
arbiter of the date when it began and
the date when the recession ended
um even though we used two quarters of
negative gdp that's not really the
definition it is a
comprehensive downward movement of
various sectors within the economy so
when you take that into account
um last year probably qualifies as a
recession because it was not too long as
you said
but at least it was comprehensive
everybody went down and i was looking
at the net
the nfp the job creation number we lost
about 20 million jobs in a single month
february of 2020. yes so in that sense
it qualifies as being a recession
your question was is the
time limit time produced i think this
was reduced because they just threw
everything including the kitten into the
kitchen sink so to say
the monetary policy fiscal policy in
numbers which were which make the
2008-2009 rescue look like child play
compared with what we did
therefore
we came out of it very very fast and i
have a basic principle if you now that
both of us are in santa monica
if you go and you take hundred thousand
dollars worth of hundred dollar bills
right outside in the small area and you
distribute it from a helicopter and let
it fall
the gdp of santa monica would have
increased immediately by hundred
thousand dollars yes by definition of
course that is the statistics
and as people pick up the hundred dollar
bills and they spend it there will be
more multiplied effect
that doesn't mean santa monica will
generate more employment for the next
five years
that is what has happened with the
fiscal and monetary stimulus you have
done something to get you out of the rut
immediately
and i have been a big fan of structural
reforms
i watched germany in 2003 2005 with
chancellor gerhard schroeder
and then allowing the fact that you as a
worker who do not have skills which are
in demand
if you would take a cut in your pay
the government will subsidize your
education to become a welder or a
carpenter for which there is there is
demand right
the welder or carpenter the person who
runs the firm wants to hire you because
you're cheap the government is
subsidizing
a year passes by when you're an
apprentice now you're skilled
the employer doesn't want to let go of
you and that's what happened in bringing
the german unemployment rate down
not because they ran a huge fiscal
deficit or the german there was no
bundesbank by then you had the european
central bank which was uh providing all
the cash in order to do that
but they empowered they re-empowered
they re-skilled their workforce exactly
and we've done apps we we've done the
opposite we've encouraged people to stay
out of the workforce and now they have
serious skills atrophy
and we're saying
and there's concern going forward that
we're not going to have the right
workers for the right positions
this has been 19 months of a wasted
opportunity absolutely correct that is
that is to me
is the big issue if you look at the 1.9
trillion in the in the biden stimulus
plan
or even if you look more at the 3.5 or
3.7 trillion more that the house passed
you are looking at very little that is
talked about in terms of worker training
and any established means of growing
your skill productivity
instead it's a case of let's pour more
cash into it and that will create growth
but it will not sustain it no that's
just that's that that is the traditional
definition of pork so to speak
[Music]